ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد تواصلوا مذكرات
الامير هاري التي تحكي قصه حياتها
المغتربه مع العائله الملكه وانفصالك عنها
طرحه مزيد من الجدل والفوضى بعد طرح للبيع
في الاسواق حيث بعد الطبعه الطبعه
الانجليزيه من
يقرب من المليونين ونصف المليون نسخه في
جميع الاشكال والاصدارات في اليوم الاول
من نشرها لكن
انتباه في المذكرات التي طرحها هاري في
الفتره التي انضاها في افغانستان وقصه
قتله ل 25 شخصا من حركه طالبان خلال
مشاركته الثانيه في الحرب حيث اشار الامير
هاري في مذكراته الى سفره في سته بعثات
لافغانستان اسفرت عن ازهاقي ارواحي او
ارواح بشريه
وهو امر لا يفخر به ولا يخجل منه في نفس
الوقت وفقا ما ذكرت صحيفه ترامب وقال بان
جزءا من سبب عدم شعوره بالذنب بشان ازهاق
الارواح هو انه لم ينسى ابدا هجمات الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر على نيويورك التي كان يشاهد
على التلفاز والتي كانت مرتبطه باعضاء من
حركه طالبانه وفقه مراقبين سيكون الكتاب
الان عاقبه عالقه بقوه على طريق المصالحه
التي يقول هاري انه يريدها مع عائلته كما
يبدو ان التوصل الى هدنه امر غير وارد في
الوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]
اناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوف نعمل درويش
المراسل معتمد في مجلس العموم بريطاني ومن
كابول الدكتور فضل الله ممتاز المحلله
السياسي اهلا بكم
اسمحلي ان ابدا من كابول معك يا دكتور فضل
دكتور فضل الله هل لتصريحات مهاريه التي
تحدث فيها عن استهدافه ل 25 من حركه
طالبان هل يمكن ان تتحرك الحركه على اثري
هذه التصريحات هناك مخاوف بخصوص فعل
تحيه طيبه وبعد ولكم ولديفكم
في الحقيقه من ناحيه الاخلاقيه
حد مذكرات واثاره التسريحات مذكرات الحامر
حاري لقد استنكار واسيا في جميع اوسعه
الافغاني سواء كان المخالفين لتاليبان او
التاليبان وبالتالي ليس هذا الامر فقط
انما من ناحيه الاخلاقيه سواء كان هذا
الامر هنا فخر ان يفتخر بقتل الانسان
وكذلك
استعمار الانف اه
بهذا الشكل
الاخلاقيه من الناحيه الفعليه هل للحركه
مجال همم للتحرك باي شكل من الاشكال تجاه
هذه التصريحات
في الحقيقه يعني لا نستتين نفيسه المقادير
الاخلاقيه عن المملكه انت انت تعرفين
تماما ثقافه شرقيه بالذات ربما هذا الامر
ربما يكون شيء مقبول في مجتمع الغربي ولكن
في مجتمع الشرقي امر محمق ان انا قلت ذكرت
ان هذا الامر
لقد استنكارها بين الجميع
فقط
داخل البريطاني قد طال العائله البريطانيه
من وراء هذه التصريحات الصريحه لانه هناك
تعليقات اتت من عائلات من كانوا زملاء
لهذه في الجيش والبعض يقول بان هناك مخاوف
من ان تطالهم بعض التهديدات او تنفذ في
حقهم
هو في نقطتين
يتفاخر بها وفي المقابله اللي قالها قال
ان في حاجه اسمها بوستر
من الجانبين لكن بعد انتهاء الحرب بيحسن
نوع من المكان
تقريبا
ما حدش في الجيش بيقول كده بعد ما انتهت
الحرب ما حدش بيتكلم بشكل
افراد وجنود لا سواء
كجيش منظم ولا لا فده ثانيه
فهذا الجزء من الانقضات الموجهه لهاري
الجزء الاخر بعد رجال الامن او بعض
المتخصصين في الامن همم عامله مقابلات
معهم قالوا ان هو همم الاتصال للطالبان
بجامعات ارهابيه حول العالم بيضع افراد
اسرته في خطر وانا كان من الحماقه انه
يذكر هذا اصلا الفعل اللي موجوده ولكن هو
فعلا همم يضعهم في خطر عند تصريحه بهذا
الشكل
لا انا ملوكه نظر الشخصيه طبعا لا لان
المنظمات
اللي بتشتغل معهم لها
اجندات معينه في استخدام الارهاب لاغراض
السياسيه
واعتقد ان
صحيح ان هذه حتكون بروفايل عالي لكن ايه
هو الغرض الدعائي اللي ممكن يكسبوه من
وراء ده حاليا لهم مشاكل اخرى مشاكل اخرى
اللي معاهم طبعا معاملتهم للنساء معاملتهم
للتعليم منظمات
الاعانه والغاوي فلم فلهم مشاكل اكثر
تعقيدا من ان هم يكسبوا همم حاجه دعائيه
حلوه العمل ضد الامير
هي حكومه غير معترف بها علاقتها مع
المجتمع الدولي علاقه يمكن وصفها بالمتوتر
لهذا السبب قد تفقد حقها في الرد باي
شكلهم من الاشكال القانونيه الدبلوماسيه
تعتقد بعد هذه التصريحات
ليس كذلك الدبلوماسيه الان هنا في
افغانستان ان رايت كثير من صفحات
الاجتماعيه كذلك
لا متالبان كذلك ان هذا الامر استنكروا
استنكروا واسع في نفس الوقت نشر الصور
الانف المضاد نشر صور كثير من صور القتلى
الغربيين ليست فقط
همم
القتل الذين قتلوا في افغانستان الذين
مثل هذا ما هذا الامر يعتبر ترويتش همم
احياء ترميجا الانف وهذا لا همم لا ينحسر
بريتانيين وبايله المالكه وانما هذا الذي
ممكن يكون هذا مضاد يكون يشمل الجميع حتى
الناس المتعاونين الذين
يشتغلوا في حكومه السابقه في عهد اشرف غني
هذا الامر ليس مساله بسيطه لهذا امر اخر
الاخوه همم امين حاري الذي ارتكب هذه
اخطاء اقول او اج همم لا ينبغي ان نستعمل
كلمات سيئه وهنا اا امرنا ان هناك كان
قضايا نسائيه الان اغلاق همم مدارس البنات
وكذلك الجامعات وحقوق المراه الان انها
غطت هذه المساله في افغانستان تحت غطاءها
هذه المساله نهائيا هذه يعتبر جريمه اخرى
لان طالبان الان يستدللونه هذا منطق يكون
ها انتم الذين كنتم تقول ها هو الاعمال
الغربيه في بلدنا في افغانستان يعني شوف
استاذ عادل ما يقول ضيف يعني يقول حتى من
كان لا يتعاطف معه
يريد ان يسمع عليه هذه الامور وحتى حكومه
طالبان اصبحت تستعمل مثل هكذا تصريحات
لتغلف على اخطاء اخرى همم فهل التصريحات
يبدو بان لها ابعاد
يعني تخطط حدود بريطانيا همم وفي هذا هل
يمكن ان تتحرك همم
الحكومه البريطانيه
لوقف هذه التصريحات تعتقد او هذا مستبعد
تماما
البريطانيه او اي حكومه غربيه
ديمقراطيه
قانونيه منع كتاب او منع تصريحات النفسيه
حريه النشره حريه التعبير يجوز اساسي
بالعكس يعني
يتضمن تصريحات قد تشوه الجيش البريطاني او
قد تحدث خطرا او تسبب في خطر على الامن
القومي
لا يوجد لا يوجد قانون يمكن اللجوء اليه
لمنع كتاب من النشر او منع احد من التعبير
عن رايه وهو طبعا كان في تعليقات الصحف
وحتى
راي شعبيه الامير هاري منخفضه الى اكثر
جزء لها بلاها الاقلام التصريحات حول
افغانستان ولكن رساله نشر الكتاب لان طبعا
صحف اليسار بتقول دي
بيكشف اسرار
الملكان الاول من السؤال هل
ده بيفيد الطالبان او لا لا يوجد لا يوجد
فيها افغانستان وسائل الاستطلاع الرايه
ليس لدينا ادوات الاستطلاع الراي لمعرفه
مدى تاثير هذه تصريحات ولا حتى نعرف ماذا
الشعبيه
اول شكرا لكم
درويش
بريطانيا
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]